so the thing that people have been
saying about CS Go versus CS2 is that
the movement in CS2 feels like absolute
dog one of the things I've actually
never really liked about CS go if I'm
being completely honest how ice skating
the game actually is making the game
feel a little bit more grounded is
actually not a bad thing and I think
that's a little bit of a hot take
there's a lot of people out there right
now saying how like valve are like
killing movement because people are
gonna come after you and they're gonna
say like no the movement in CS go is
perfect and if you touch it it's like
sacrosanct and it's so skillful and you
can express yourself when people come
from valorant the biggest thing they
have to get used to is the fact that CS
goes is such a fast game it's so quick
and I think slowing the game down and
making it a little bit more
grounded is honestly not a bad thing I
think the idea in principle of valves
slowing down Counter-Strike and making
the movement a little bit more
accessible is really actually not
necessarily a bad thing as long as it
feels good